hey know what's your name Riley what I'm
Riley okay we got heavy makeup fake hair
this is the Modern Woman outfit fake
teeth fake hair fake butt where you from
Chicago you know where the I'm from how
I was supposed to know that man you
know get get the how the hell I'm
supposed to know where the from nobody
don't nobody know about you and nobody's
going to look [__]
up that is wife material right there
what up guys welcome to the just cly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series make sure you like the
video on your way in and get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt to support
the channel the link is in the
description today I'm going to be
reacting to a desperate IG model getting
rejected and laughed at as you guys know
we have seen this overwhelming trend of
Instagram models thinking they are the
hottest things since sliced bread they
get a couple of Instagram followers they
get some clout they get a bit of
attention from celebrities and they then
think they are wife material and so
amazing and awesome unfortunately we
have an entire economy that profits off
of these women and lies to them for a
lifetime until they hit 35 and realize
they're about to die alone so we are
going to watch a Instagram model getting
rejected yes let's let's see and most of
these women have no idea how delusional
or stupid that they look because men
will never tell you and will generally s
for a Life Time really deserve that
what
what are
you hey I no Riley what I'm Riley okay
we got heavy makeup fake hair BBL as you
guys we've talked about this before this
is the Modern Woman outfit typically
it's something immodest typically it is
something where she has had plastic
surgery a lot of time fake teeth fake
hair fake butt all of all of the how you
doing I'm good where you from I'm from
Kentucky oh all I with you though I with
you R what you was saying spin around
turn around he want you to spin around
turn around again again one more time
one more time one more time one more
time you're a victim what's up what's up
what's up I like your you asking me
questions what the okay okay okay okay I
guess these girls are trying to win his
affection I'm going tell you what so
look no idea who this guy is where you
from
Chicago you know where the I'm from how
I was supposed to know that man you know
where I'm from how you a know why the
you here the F you a you ain't look up
nothing bye how the you don't know where
I'm from you talking to me get yeah he's
like ladies you're trying to win my
affection I would have said it I would
have been a little more polite I would
have been like you are very unprepared
ma'am next get get getu on how the hell
I'm supposed to know where the [__] you
from nobody nobody know about you nobody
[__]
up you
[__] you look like wow what a gal that
is wife material right there light skin
why your hairline so far back bye [__]
he might have said it the wrong way but
he got a point if I'm signing up for a
show to go date a celebrity the least I
can do is Google him so I know who I'm
talking to but he was acting too cocky
so she had to cook bro he got his ass
cooked you want a Cris the nice you're a
[__] creepy [__] I'm sicking you
after the hospital you're not right you
better go somewhere and beat your meat
have mercy I'm about to
bust good catch I am packing um I pray
that I only have ever have to use it
against Bears and walls but if I ever do
come up against a two-legged snakes with
evil intentions how was how are the are
the Amish on Tik Tok I will use it isn't
their whole thing no technology this
back to the right to the left mop it up
clean it up do you do anything El to
help you relax I mean I'm like I take
baths I'm Pisces yeah I drink I'm an
alcoholic I smoke I'm a Cancer astrology
is just a way for people to blame their
character flaws on something that they
can't she say she is is a bath a
character flaw are is that like a bad
thing now control so they don't have to
change them if I'm lying I'm dying shut
your goofy ass and go back to the
kitchen you're 35 go make your kid a
sandwich I'm going to [__] your dad and
give him a child he actually loves
I oh wow beg your pardon are you guys a
couple yeah yeah yeah okay so I was
asking the couples um let's say he
wanted you to change outfits cuz he
thought you were dressing too [__]
what would you tell them uh I'll tell I
deem this outfit I have a new Twitter
Series where I deem outfits wife and
mother worthy I say for a wife and a
mother this is either modest or immodest
I deem this immodest see-through there's
like a bikini on under there and it's a
bit I'm a Catholic this is a bit
disrespectful I mean if you're going to
dress up as a nun could you not do a
[__] nun like that's a bit get with
the program it's escape and we young and
turn how do you feel about that I don't
really care I mean everybody else is
dressed like this and I mean if she's
going to dress like that got guys
looking at her then obviously there's
I'm going to be looking at [__] too you
know what I mean everybody's getting
turned so [__] it we're we're here
having fun we're here having fun he said
just because you full don't me you can't
look at the menu if you can dress
however you want I can look at whatever
I want equality it's my
turn oh
no
hello no no no no no no
oh I would kill her I would be so pissed
I would be like lady you had one
job oh he's
pissed and Jennifer I would not give you
the sweat off my if you were dying of
thirst and that shows her
character like it has it has to be Chef
boy Rd too
specifically Chef boy RV can ravioli H
can
ravioli you can't have Che but you can
Che
nuts you want to you want to go upstairs
upstairs we can't go upstairs I'm happen
to go nerd a kid told you let's go
upstairs you said yeah let's go
upstairs oh she had a boyfriend oh wow I
wanted to pee with the kid no the only
way I was able to even get upstairs is
because of
him they weren't going to let anyone
upstairs so out of everyone in the house
they would only let neon tell to go
upstairs yes a kid yes a kid neon was
the was the bathroom
Commander I hope he broke up with her I
don't think he did if he's doing all
this I don't I think he's still with her
I'm going to guess if your girlfriend
out here getting saued by streamers
that's not your girlfriend that's our
girlfriend if she had a party without
you especially if it's at some dude's
house I don't think she's there to talk
about our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
and dressed like that you know Jesus
can't save these ho why are you trying
can can you spell me do I look stupid m
a
little me e you forgot the D there's no
D in me not
yet jalapeno peppers raw are the best
stop [__] anything raw is
good what's going on nothing why are you
driving in the wrong way of traffic no I
just got changed around I just moved
here like two months ago and I just got
changed
around how do you get I've I've moved a
lot of times guys I have to tell you
I've moved quite a bit in my life I
lived Chicago I lived in the Chicago
country I lived close to the city in
college I also lived in Milwaukee also
lived in London and never have I ever
just driven the wrong way in traffic
because I moved that story is not adding
up chica I'm not a detective okay I know
this is a real top I'm not a detective
but my Spidey senses are going okay do
you understand what's going on though
you're going into oncoming traffic I
know and I just decided that it was
better just to turn around really quick
okay but I'm sorry I just have like
really about social anxiety and stuff
huh now look I know some people with
social anxiety it's a real thing um I
would say it comes from not like a lot
of my generation and lower not really
learning how to prop ly socialize with
people but I I can't say that's going to
make you drive into oncoming traffic I'm
not I'm not a detective but my my Spidey
senses are still going I don't want to
step out whenever you're asking
for stuff okay well we're past that just
go ahead and step out as an indigenous
person that chick looks whiter than me
and I'm pretty white guys I'm pretty I'm
pretty pale I I she looks paler than me
that takes a lot I I'm not saying that
she isn't indigenous okay I'm not saying
that but I am saying my Spidey senses
are going
off right back here please Miss Perry am
I well I'm non-binary so okay what do
you go back all
right now I'm not a detective but but I
mean she's got long hair I see some
boobs there she could just be fat I
don't know I'm going to guess it's a she
who knows I've been fooled before I'm
just going to guess what do you go buy
this Kai how can I refer to you tonight
Kai okay hey I'm smelling alcohol I know
how much have you consumed tonight like
probably three drin I need to run you
through some tests right now stand
facing me please but I just want you to
know that I also have very bad social
anxiety you and me
both okay okay any recent head trauma uh
traumatic brain injuries anything I need
to know about uh mental
yes focus on my finger please I am
you're just like trying to intimidate me
I now I'm not a detective right I'm not
I'm not I'm not a detective but he's not
really coming off as intimidating to me
I I don't know I don't know maybe
there's some trauma everyone's got this
trauma nowadays trauma trauma trauma
I'll keep watching I'll keep watching
how I'm trying to do that this is the
test as you know as an indigenous person
and there's a bunch of all right guys do
you know how hard it is to be paler than
me I am a ginger I am a ginger there
who's paler than a ginger this chick now
I'm not saying I'm not saying that she
doesn't have indigenous whatever all I'm
saying is I'm skeptical this sounds like
an Elizabeth Warren it does going around
we don't care let me let me tell we
don't care I'm sorry but it's just for
me to be on my toes I get you can you
remember that wrinkle my toes and he
stinkle my nose you know the song I told
you that a
nonbinary yeah I'll try my hardest I'll
refer to you as Kai right yes perfect I
need to know if you have any injuries or
anything that would prevent you from
doing a standard walk or a turn tonight
mental health um any physical
injuries mentally yeah but no I'm just
saying mental PTS see depression anxiety
I get you what else you want now with
your right foot place it in front of
your left in a heel to toe touching
manner with your arms by your side just
like this ma'am can you not call me
ma'am please I'm trying my hardest okay
well okay it means a lot to me I'm
trying my hardest I don't feel like a
man so okay it's kind of triggering
right foot in front of your left nope go
back I'm sorry about that whole man
thing just
like I apologize let's see if we can
move forward from
it oh this cop deserves a medal for like
patience this is the most patient cop
have zero
questions no but I just want to tell you
that I suffer from really bad anxiety
especially with generational trauma and
PTSD you can ptsd's nuts at this point
point people are just self diagnosing
mental illnesses so they can claim
victimhood if you tell you have PTSD and
it isn't immediately followed up with
the story of how you lost your leg I'm
not buying it let's just be honest
especially if you a white woman from the
suburbs you ain't got to worry about no
PTSD you got to worry about obesity
around hey hey I have a lot of trauma
thank you all right white people and
cops
like all right it's
just I'm going to speak with you right
over here okay no yes ma'am go ahead and
place your hands behind your back don't
dude don't make it hard please don't
make it hard no you're you're going to
get a resistance dude I you're going to
get to resist I don't don't resist don't
listen to me don't resist don't you're
being a white man and don't I followed
all of your like I an indigenous person
like you guys wow it's like this is like
a a kid adult you guys are scared
me there's nothing to be afraid of the
funny thing about women it's like when
they get caught they'll kind of cry the
men will the man will just like take the
lowl and be like yeah all right this is
called generational TR you're going to
jail she's drinking and driving on the
wrong side of the road and she thinks
she's getting arrested because she's
indigenous if you just trying to get out
of being arrested at this point you
might as well tell him you going to suck
them
off
[Music]
I I'm not saying it's a good thing and
I'm not saying it's going to work I'm
just saying statistically speaking it
has to work better than saying you have
PTSD let me know yeah um I I'm not a
detective guys I'm not sure she's
indigenous I'm not sure she really has
trauma like that but I'm pretty sure
she's drunk I I'm not a detective I'm
not in law enforcement I don't know
maybe I'm crazy but my Spidey senses are
Tak but let me know what you guys think
in the comments this is why women
shouldn't vote we buy into this [__]
and we just go nuts get yourself a
t-shirt in the description I'll talk to
you guys next time